highlight was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen in meinem video ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut ohne wirtsleute
zurzeit es ist wirklich wirklich oftmals
ich mache es gerne aber es ist eine
zumutung in diesem büro hier meine
ganzen retouren videos zu drehen weil
das ist mal so fucking heißt man kann
sich nicht vorstellen ich bin eigentlich
durchgehend am schwitzen auf jeden fall
habe ich vor ungefähr zwei wochen danach
von moore bekommen dann legen wir auch
hin und wieder schon mal ware gekauft
haben eigentlich mal ganz cool dass er
neue sachen hat und ich hier nicht
einmal vorbeikommen sollte auch einiges
von amazon ich bin hingefahren und hat
mir das mal angeschaut und das schauen
wir uns hier mal an richtung schon mal
gucken und sagen müssen wir dann
gefährden nicht dass ich mir hier bei
der ein oder anderen palette irgendwas
raus nickel hat man hier was hier alles
rumsteht 1000 kartons alles hier von
amazon finde das immer höchst
interessant die nehme ich jetzt sie zwar
nicht aber gucken hier kann man gucken
wie die wehr jetzt
wieso eigentlich nicht mehr sag mal so
lange der preis stimmt muss hier mal 10
die zeiten nicht schnell ein so leute
musste sich gerne umziehen und etwas zu
trinken holen wir sind hier heute wieder
münster und ich dachte mir ist jetzt
zwei wochen im urlaub haben brauchen
geworden wie du siehst naja dann hab ich
jetzt mal heutigen tag genutzt wenn hier
hingefahren und moment hat nämlich ein
paar neue coole sachen hiermit sein kann
richtig also ich hab heute für dich hier
so ein bisschen amazon das multimedia
und aushalten muss man wissen was
spannendes ich weiß es immer
überraschungen haben sie die habe ich
einfach mal zwei kartons öffnet ja und
dann drehten den räten in vielen denn du
bekommst du siehst ja ok das werde ich
gut aber ich brauche noch irgendwas
anderes schauen was wir noch den
alleskönner ist leider ein bisschen
gefüllt oder haben einiges dh also man
sieht auf jeden fall noch voller als
beim letzten mal okay leute wir schauen
uns jetzt mal um und ich glaube ich
möchte mich dann wieder bei mir zu hause
und dann hoffen wir mal dass auf gute
sache und überraschungsgäste designs gab
es eine dicke fisch werde
leute was geht ich befinde mich gerade
in meinem büro und habe von eco wächst
der neuen tcn turbo tauchroboter
zugeschickt bekommt mit reinigungs
stationen und so weiter und so fort also
wirklich die absolute luxus variante in
meiner wohnung habe ich ja bereits den
x1 uni der auch so eine dicke station
hat die technik von accenture nie wurde
auf dem tcn tor übertragen die beiden
saugroboter sehen auch ähnlich aus
gehört aber nicht zugleich eine serie
der t10 turbo hat nämlich lediglich die
t serie ab geredet und ich dachte mir ja
kommen gehen hier muss ich auf jeden
fall in meinem büro stellen weil ich
muss sagen ich bin mittlerweile
eigentlich fast vielmehr hier im büro
als zu hause und da ist es ja auch immer
wirklich schön wenn alles blitzeblank
ist und heute mal entspannt ausgepackt
und auch schon installiert funktioniert
alles einwandfrei so sieht das gerät aus
ich würde sagen wirklich wunderschönen
passt auch einfach sehr gut hier rein
und ja ich gebe jetzt mal ein paar
versuchen wir schauen mal was das ding
so kann let's go kamera kamera
ihr könnt höheren leute gerade werden
die wischmopps befeuchtet so habt ihr
halt wirklich einen tophit erlebnis
abfahrt
das sieht doch gut aus schönen
saubermachen kollege ja ich bin der
absolute profis am roboter tester das
sieht stabil aus
heute was neues bei dem er kennt jetzt
gerade zur reinigung station zurück um
einmal die vips neu zu befeuchten und
danach wieder volle reinigungsqualität
abliefern zu können wo ab in ein
häuschen einmal reinigen würde
also das ist wirklich wie eine
waschstraße so leute der t10 turbo dreht
hier immer noch seine runden ich muss
sagen ich bin aber froh weil dann ist
das büro gleich blitzeblank für mich
gibt finde ich morgen zehn tage nach
malle und ich habe es immer gerne wenn
ich halt so dann ihr meine heimat
verlassen und alles sauber ist und da
bin ich meiner neuen hilfe hier im büro
auf jeden fall dankbar leute wenn ihr
interessiert seid am tencent turbo
ecoflex hat auch jede menge andere
günstigere modelle das ist natürlich
schon eine premium alternative stoff da
musst du nicht rein da ist gerade mir
dazu gestellt alles gut aber danke
fristen für das versuchen wir gerne den
link ganz oben in der bestellung ab da
kommen die zuwächse und amazon link ist
auch verlinkt leute und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit dem video letzte
also wie man hier sehen kann hätte es ja
gar keine top down ist amazon logo hier
haben wir auch nochmal unten in amazon
logo ich habe mir zwei von diesen dicken
paketen ausgesucht ein paket hat 100
euro kostet auch für mo im einkauf 200
euro oder war alles 1a retouren ware wir
haben wenig markenprodukte soweit ich
weiß viel fbl stand aber ist nicht
schlimm bei die wird trotzdem gewaltiger
wer drin sein war damit zumindest gesagt
also schon einmal bezahlt und ihr könnt
es leute wir bleiben hier unten ein ob
sich das ganze lohnt oder nicht aber ich
bin da eigentlich ganz guter dinge das
singstar schwer und ja schauen wir
einfach mal und ich kann ja ungefähr die
ware die mol verkauft und wir haben hier
auf jeden fall viel ermessen fbi ware
ist aber gar nicht so schlecht weil
manchmal sind da wirklich gute sachen
dabei ich sehe aber auch schon eine
marke die ich kenne und ich habe ja noch
ein zweites paket mitgenommen mit etwas
anderen waren ich habe keine ahnung ob
ich das auch in dieses video paket leute
werden einfach mal sehen naja ok starten
wir mal als erstes haben wir hier von
braun braun extra fit 5 ein wecker nie
was ist das denn immer braun die marke
kennt man ja der ja ich wusste gar nicht
dass die blutdruck geräte produzieren
aber machen sie anscheinend schauen wir
doch einfach mal brauen exakt 5 guck mal
also mindestens 46 euro und das ist auf
jeden fall ungeöffnet oder warte mal ist
es eine retoure okay es ist auf jeden
fall geöffnet worden aber da frauen
haben was drin wieder eigentlich ganz
gut aus sogar noch eine folie darüber
dass mit dieser batterie passiert also
es ist ja meistens so dass keine
batterien mitgeliefert werden das heißt
der käufer hat die batterien bringen
gelassen und sound das ist mir dieser
batterie passiert das ist das hier
irgendwie nicht so gesund aus
blutdruckmessgerät muss ich jetzt nicht
testen ich denke mal wir wissen alle wie
das funktioniert aber 45 euro ist ja
eigentlich schon mal ein stabiler staat
hat ist dass man verschieben euch mal
ein bisschen drüber beschuldigungen evas
wie ach so ein videoprojekt rajan beamer
oder was ist das ist ja will der hat
auch schnell man wert ohne kabel an hier
haben wir das kabel alles noch ganz
passend eingepackt und preislich sind
die dinger auch absolut in ordnung
welchen haben wir dann hier ich sehe
gerade schon 130 euro w13 also der
kostet auf jeden fall über 100 euro das
ist schon krass jetzt sehe ich hier
gerade leute es gibt einfach ein beamer
für 28.000 euro dgf ich wünsche euch
immer ein was ist das denn barcoo
projektor f9 verkauft sich der beamer
für 30.000 euro zu also bis jetzt läuft
ja ganz gut ich würde lieber mal mit 120
euro bepreisen dann haben wir hier als
nächstes technische parameter
hsh meinte ja eine steckdose die aus
einer steckdose zwei steckdosen macht
oder aus einer steckdose zwei steckdosen
plus vier usb-ports also eigentlich gar
nicht so schlecht ist kann nicht
wirklich wir brauchen jetzt kann ich
hier bei dem ich in der ecke seht ich
kann jetzt gleichzeitig da habe ich mir
hier mal ein bisschen abgefragt moment
als judas mal auf die lampe ist nämlich
jetzt aus wenn jetzt gleichzeitig die
lampe anschließend wie jetzt auch nicht
wieder alles wunderbar dann kann ich
noch hier meine geräte laden sagt wenn
man nämlich zwei verschiedene kabel
unter anderem diese kopfhörer perfekt es
gibt sogar nicht so es ist natürlich
nicht allzu teuer ich würde mal schätzen
15 euro und solarworld was ist denn das
solarenergie keller hat kann man damit
tiere rufen oder was ich ja noch nie
gesehen geht irgendwie aus wie so ein
süßes männer könnten taube kommt 1009
tschuldigung damit kann man keine tiere
und damit verscheucht man sie so dann
steckt man das hier drauf und dann mach
das jetzt irgendwelche sound hört ihr
ach jetzt stecke ich das soll neue sein
wird ihr das
also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
wirklich tiere verscheucht aber also
eigentlich sehr freundlich aus halo okay
machen wir das mal schnell wieder aus
kostet 18 euro 99 g weiter geht es mit
dem nächsten und wieder was wird geboten
das sich aber gut aus sie haben wir so
ein dino von gussteilen hat dass
irgendwas mit rich zu tun ich könnte
auch mal wieder ein neues video machen
oder leuchten wenn ich das machen soll
last auf jeden fall meinen daumen nach
oben da alter hier sind ja auch viele
dinos drin war früher ich hätte schwöre
ich hatte mich gebt euch mal den ich
hätte mich so darüber gefreut und da
kann man wahrscheinlich sogar batterien
rein ballern und dann macht er irgendwas
oder
und mir geht es ja alles gut so weit das
ist schön hier und hier bald noch
weitere die nuss drin die qualität von
dem ding ist halt irgendwie ein bisschen
weg aber sonst bricht ein dinosaurier
gebraucht 17 euro neue 45 euro taxe und
hier ist auch eine fernbedienung bei das
heißt man kann den steuern tatsächlich
dann fährt er halt so da geht nicht
erfährt ja toll finde ein wasserkocher
ist ein wasserkocher oder eigentlich
bräuchte ich so was zu hause ich habe
keinen pc und so geht auch noch schön
kaputt neu aus keine ahnung 20 euro
vielleicht 25 euro ich denke mal die 200
euro haben wir jetzt auf jeden fall
mittlerweile wieder rauf geht's der
webcam full hd mexiko webcam ja auch
eher unspektakulär kostet circa 30 euro
und was ist das hier nmhh würde ich mal
schätzen 10 oder wo keine ahnung mit
dass kann ich mir jetzt nicht so gut aus
aber das hat erfahrungsgemäß keinen wert
lag stars dream rotating projekt der mdr
hatte lebenslang im tik tok mittlerweile
sind die dinger glaube ich ein bisschen
aus der mode und jetzt muss es
eigentlich mal wieder ein bisschen
interessanter werden hier haben wir eine
u100 es ist eine überwachungskamera aber
die sieht irgendwie krass aus hier leute
schaut zu machen also wenn die an meinem
haus hängt dass ich noch nicht besitzt
dann bin ich auf jeden fall gut
geschützt 50 euro bei amazon noch in
einem guten zustand man sieht doch gut
aus perfekt wir haben hier den nächsten
led projektor tricks durch beamer und
der macht von der qualität her noch
einen besseren eindruck und deshalb viel
schwerer als der ebene das wird glaube
ich ein glücksgriff guck mal kabel ist
auch natürlich dabei wir haben hier eine
tasche die mitgeliefert wird würde
schätzen der kostet über 200 euro alles
hier noch schön eingepackt ist aber
leider von der gleichen marke wie heißt
du modell jg 420 140 naja egal also ist
ja besser als nix hätte irgendwie
gedacht dass der teurer ist aber 140
euro ist ja trotzdem alles andere als
schlecht weiß nicht wo wir mittlerweile
liegen aber ein bisschen was haben wir
noch hier zum beispiel mit der ketsch
camps gehen auch immer gut ich würde mal
sagen eine des camp vielleicht behalte
ich auch weil irgendwie feiere ich dass
mir passiert auch manchmal so dumme
verkehrssituation da wünscht man sich
eigentlich immer eine dash camp und des
camps wo das macht eigentlich in guten
eindruck dass dingen alles noch schön
neu verpacken der marke es so wenn ich
nicht aber was kostet die ok so teuer
ist sie nicht irgendwas zwischen 55 und
70 euro aber immerhin hat es das denn
noch im herbst rater keine ahnung marke
kenne ich nicht 30 euro wenn denn
überhaupt irgendwer kauf und hier haben
wir mit track
wahrscheinlich ist es eine waage die
werde ich so was von safe behalten weil
ich habe einfach keine waage zu hause
und da mache ich jetzt mal eben die
batterien rein und schauen wir einfach
mal wie schwer ich wiege das müsste
eigentlich passen von der größe her egal
das kann jetzt nicht wahr sein scheiße
passt nicht aber irgendwo batterien
leider keine batterien in meinem büro
aber ich werde dir auf jeden fall testen
und dann wahrscheinlich auch bald die in
kurzen würde wagen ist installiert ob
man das jetzt geht betrieben drin wo ist
das sind
163 kilogramm geht's noch leute ich muss
mir jetzt auch so eine app holen da
kannst du dann irgendwie alles checken
von ihrer comeback tour ist nie schlecht
wenn es das zu viel verlangt es ist halt
einfach keine waage dir jetzt einmal an
zeigen wer ich bin da gibt es dann gegen
seinen fettanteil und so denn ist nichts
für mich aber naja videos so stabiles
oder ich bin zu der fitness in florenz
habe ich mich ein jetzt geht es
entscheidend ha ha ha ha
ja schöne füße ich weiß haben jetzt
zeigen
17,7 leute ich habe jetzt übrigens auch
seinen eigenen amazon shop wo ich immer
die produkte aus einem videos listen
werde so sieht das ganze aus ihr könnt
ja gerne mal vorbeischauen ist ab jetzt
in meiner video beschreibung verlinkt wo
die kosten auf die wir einfach 155 euro
die gibt es auch günstiger 40 eur 19
also dann habe ich wenigstens meine
waage zu hause kann ja nicht haben er
hier ist ja noch so viel drin wir sind
jetzt schon fast 2000 euro oder hier
sind wirklich ich muss sagen das paket
für 200 euro auf jeden fall richtig dass
ich das gekauft habe ich komme mir
welche aussuchen einfach hier nur ich
habe keine uhr zuhause brauche ich
eigentlich auch nicht wer mein handy
obwohl ich habe eine uhr am handgelenk
und jetzt sehe ich gerade die uhr haben
wir auch noch ein zweites mal würde ich
mal sagen wenn ihr also insgesamt 40
euro dann haben wir hier noch mal diesen
hairdresser und jetzt haben wir hier
noch einige pakete jobmarkt keramik ptc
hatte ach das ist eine heizung zu
interessant so lastring leitbild onlive
ist das ein rocker glaube hier könnte
auch noch was dabei sein was wirklichen
wert hat wir fangen einfach mal mit dem
körper keramik etc kita angedacht ist
halt einfach noch heizungen auch immer
an
ich muss die ausladen ach nee ich glaube
die leute haben wir noch so lastring
leiht den euro ist wie so eine
lichterkette wahrscheinlich nicht mal
zehn euro dann haben wir hier noch wahr
ist dass chefs
weihnachten wunderschönen sogar mit
schnee drauf hat ist das denn hier sind
becher könnte jetzt wieder erfolgreich
denen die meinen ton reingeschossen hat
deswegen muss ich das jetzt noch mal
kurz nachsehen diesem alter ich gucke
auch manchmal wirklich wie der letzte
affe in diesem videos irgendwelche
produkte an ich habe keine ahnung was
das hier war es hat sich danach heraus
gestellt dass es eine
zahnbürsten station ist wo man seine
ganzen zahlen putz und hat sie liehen
reinpacken kann und für mich sah deshalb
wirklich einfach nur komisch aus er wie
so ein ding was jeden moment in der luft
liegt aber meine zahnbürste tue ich das
sicherlich nicht rein als letztes habe
ich dann hier noch diesen tonner nennt
sich das nie das ist ein so ein koch
erweiterungs gerät womit man essen
kochen kann wie das genau funktioniert
habe ich nicht verstanden aber die
dinger kosten zwischen 60 70 euro und ja
ich habe so etwas noch nie gesehen aber
gut vier grad mal wieder mein mikro
eingeschlossen deswegen müssen jetzt das
ende noch mal machen ich glaube wir
haben auf jeden fall ein warenwert von
1000 euro reicht das ganz gut ist lette
ging auf jeden fall gut klar und ich
habe hier auch zum beispiel eine neue
fitness werke für zuhause und meine
fitness sei ansonsten auf jeden fall
lustige produkte dabei und ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen leute danke fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal haut rein